can be I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here that banner
[Music]
[Applause]
he's not here somebody's shopping for
under this
being naughty
[Music]
somebody's wearing a dirty scarf around
their neck oh it's you
to come over
[Applause]
some way from you
Wow it's never too late to come over
right there and that is Stevie starlight
and some people think like who's Stevie
starlight you know it sounds like
somebody you know that uh you know
rollerskates around and just you know
puts dirty peppermints into the mouths
of adolescents or you know middle aged
children you know who's Stevie starlight
and the answer is I don't [ __ ] know
who it is because that's the way the
world works now somebody sends me an
email they said hey I'm Stevie starlight
and this is my life's work this is the
magnum opus of my existence this is this
dirty naughty hit and that Stevie
starlight right there and that is called
come over
some way
and that's that's the kind of song you
hear if you're like you know if you
broke into somebody's house and you're
trying on their clothes you know that's
what I feel like you know that's what's
T that's that's TV starlight and Stevie
starlight sounds like the kind of dude
you would never let babysit a kid
obviously yeah he might you know have an
ad on the Internet to be a babysitter
might also have ulterior motives and
that's just my um that's just my you
know I'm just basing this solely on on
the name's Stevie starlight or he could
be the [ __ ] awesomest airplane pilot
you ever get on a plane with imagine you
get on an airplane you get on the guy
has a [ __ ] no shirt on the pilot zero
shirts you think he has a shirt on well
apparently you're not look you're not
getting a good look at him because he
does not he's got on chest hair he's got
on the Southwest his us
it says Southwest tattooed across his
chest pierced nipples both of them
pierced and in each piercing has like a
half of a heart hanging off of it one
half says B II Fri the other half
hanging off the other nipple says st e
NDS he has a best friend's heart hanging
half and a half of each you know
slippery little need a little nerve
ending little dirty little brown baby
titty nipple and that's Stevie starlight
imagine you get on that airplane and
there he is
you're like where are we going captain
and he just cranks it up
[Applause]
[Music]
you know you're going you're going to
[ __ ] heaven that's where you're going
dude that's the only place this jet goes
Newark too
[Music]
[Applause]
but you know what this is guys this is
that comeback music this will make you
stomp your foot dude this will make you
[ __ ] just put your both your fingers
into a baby's mouth and just take that
little whatever you gave them some cream
peaches or whatever you just fed them
it'll make you take it right back out of
their mouth and just eat it right in
front of them you can see right now you
feel Suzie just goodbye and the baby is
just like looking like the baby's like
what yeah baby that's what happens in
this universe welcome to the world
because sometimes people will take the
food right out of your mouth and I'm
just fired up today because I'm back man
that's what I felt like when this went
on when I saw this hit from Stevie
starlight this come over that's that
that's what I just this is like Rocky
it's like that Rocky music but for like
a guy who sometimes questions is
sexuality and that's what I felt I mean
it just like man that's that Stevie
starlight and I want to thank you guys
for being here with me welcome to this
past Thursday and this is that comeback
you know last on Monday I just felt
rattled man I just didn't feel I didn't
feel good you know I just felt now it's
thinking about how I felt and and I
guess I just felt a lot of fear man I
just felt I felt like the episode or
just be I just I don't know I just
didn't feel good you know I didn't feel
that good and I just didn't
I just felt disconnected you know I just
felt disconnected not been doing
everything that I kind of need to do to
stay connected because for me I have to
follow our to have to try to follow a
you know organized set of um you know
things each day to try and stay
connected and I've been doing that and I
just and I was feeling not connected and
that was you know it was just getting a
little bit scary to me but I want to
thank some of you guys that reached out
and um and just said hey man you know
you know keep your head up everything's
okay you know what sometimes we just
have to hear that sometimes we have to
hear somebody say that to us and so I
appreciate it that was some of you guys
at UH that did that and I just was just
afraid I was thinking about it I guess I
was just afraid you know I had some fear
that you know we've been getting more
listeners to the to the show and we have
like we have you know some we have some
exciting plans coming up for this year
and for the coming months we're gonna do
a state of the podcast address on on on
Mondays out upcoming episode we're just
going to kind of you know we have some
things that are you know gonna happen
that we want to start to um you know
unravel out in the universe and I guess
I was just feeling like a lot of
pressure you know and I was and I just I
just kind of lost my you ever seen a
baby deer sometime if a baby deer gets
born they come out of their mom first of
all a baby deer walks out backwards into
the world do you know that some animals
come out front words humans you know
figures dude idiot humans coming out
front words would an idiot because
somebody can attack your head
immediately say you're being born and
there's a damn war going on or there's a
fire and you stick your head out first
what an idiot you're an idiot and when I
say you I mean all of us because that's
how we do it and that should show us
right there that humans we're not it's
you know it's not a we're not really
probed we're not we're kind of just done
a little we go headfirst into the world
I mean it's brave you know it's
adventurous it's it's that pioneer
spirit but to a Matt think about this
you've there's it's a place you've never
been because you've never been anywhere
because you're brand new into the
universe as far as we know and you're
gonna stick your head out there first
what a damn
Muppet what a greased up damn snicker
sniffing Muppet it's crazy and that's
why I breach birthers I trust a breach
birth or more often and I wish that if
we should all have to wear a little name
tag that says if we were breached or
headfirst because while headfirst it's
brave and everything also way idiot
yeah never been in the universe before
I'm just gonna stick my head out first
well that's nuts so breech birth is at
least alike and we'll put a toe into the
universe and see how it feels
maybe I'll put two feet in the universe
way more and if a breech birth if it's a
fire if it's a war or if somebody lops
their heads off their legs off you still
we still got the rest of your body you
can still get born and go live out in
the world in a wheelchair or on a
skateboard if you don't have any legs
sometimes when people have legs you know
you can see them on the internet it's a
lot of some men and some men and India
even they duct tape them to a skateboard
and that's their body is the skateboard
you know they still have their chests
and their genitalia and hip you know
hips but but anyhow you know that's uh
that's kind of I was just fearful
you know I was just fearful I'll just
get you know I think just some fear that
there's a lot going on and that you know
and I was that I was just gonna mess up
you know that I just lost my confidence
I lost my footing for a second and going
back to what I was talking about and
going back to what I was talking about a
baby deer they come in they back into
the universe
if you ever is sometime I'll step at
night watching any animals be born on
the internet you know and I was to
watching funerals for a while but my
therapist said I said quit watching
funerals because it's depressing and
I'll say this dude honestly a lot of the
funerals on the Internet
extremely long like most of them are
Middle Eastern if I'm talking you can
watch there's funerals on the internet
that are six hours long not and not
very bizarre exciting but also bizarre
but you can watch babies be born but
baby deers they back into the universe
but when they get here their legs are so
shaky you know their legs are just like
just long just they're almost just like
marshmallow with hoofs on the end
imagine trying to stand up on
marshmallow I mean it's tough it's
almost you know it's uh and sometimes if
you do a lot of drugs or something you
you can have that similar experience but
that's how baby deers are on their legs
shake and that's how I felt
I just felt shaky I felt like my legs
and my neck and everything was just
marshmallow and I just got I just you
know just felt like I didn't want to I
don't know I just wanted I don't know I
just didn't feel okay and and sometimes
you're gonna have days like that and so
that's just kind of what was going on
and I'm not apologizing I'm not
complaining I'm not I just was trying to
you know the past few days I was just
trying to think about what was going on
you know and sometimes [ __ ] you know
the universe is gonna be you know it's
going to be this it's going to be this
cool little crystal ball that I'm gonna
play with and look at and sometimes
universe is gonna be a damn cannon ball
that's gonna rip right by and just rip
my sister's tits off you know or it's
gonna just just come steaming fast right
through my stepdaddy's legs and just
blast his nuts into the the next uh
nutter sphere sometimes that kind of
stuffs gonna happen and that's what was
going on so I just had some fear man you
know I had some fear of of just failure
I guess I had some fear of you know I
don't know just everything that's some
fear so that's what was going on with me
and and today and today I'm feeling
better you know I've done some things I
went for a run I'm staying
I'm just staying confident I'm coming
back man I'm Stevie [ __ ] Starlite
dude I'm not Billy blackhole I'm not
Billy blackhole dude I'm just just yes
just falling in on my own
gravity and I'm just gonna go hide in my
shirt like a Punxsutawney Phil that's
lazy and don't want to get out there and
do his work and see what his [ __ ]
shadow is gonna do I'm not gonna be like
that I'm gonna be like Stevie starlight
and I'm gonna [ __ ] when my mom is at
work I'm gonna go in her room and I'm
gonna get her nightgown out of the
[ __ ] closet and I'm gonna get in
front of the mirror and I'm gonna
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna be human that's what I'm gonna
do thank you guys for joining me man
it's Thursday what's going on what's
going on in the universe I'm here you
know that you're here I appreciate you
guys for joining me and I want to thank
everybody for listening I want to thank
everybody on YouTube for subscribing
we're up to 25,000 subscribers when we
get to 30,000 I'm gonna put out some new
comedy content for you guys we have the
studio is we get some updates coming up
and I'll announce all that stuff next
week some cool stuff but but thank you
guys for being here what's been going on
with me man what's been going on in the
world that had the State of the Union
address yeah I think what gets me and
watching this and then watching the
State of the Union address and we'll
just about a lot of the politics these
days and is that it seems like like I
don't think Trump is he is a neat guy
you know I don't think he's a great
leader you know I don't think he
embodies you know I don't think he gets
people you know I think he is a sheisty
businessman but with all those things
said I don't want America to fail just
it seems like there's a lot of people
out there that want Trump to fail and
want our America to suffer so that they
can prove their point or so that they
can be right and that to me that's where
I don't understand what's going on that
doesn't that doesn't seem right to me
like I hope that I hope that he succeeds
I hope that that that there's success
for everyone I hope that there's you
know I hope that that the political that
they are able to figure things out and
they get it right and that things change
you know and I'm not even a Politico I'm
not even a fan of politics but if I
don't if
don't think that if I'm not hopeful then
Who am I like then what am i what am I
doing here then how do I even call
myself an American if I'm not hopeful
for better things in our country you
know I because it's like even if good
news comes out if something positive
happens nobody it's like there's so much
it's still negative stuff on the news
you know it's still like there's always
like a negative connotation with it like
why can't we just be excited about
something you know like black
unemployment they said and there's
caveats to this I guess but that black
unemployment was at an all-time low and
you know what I don't know I don't even
I didn't look into the stats of that you
know I didn't look into it but I'll say
this in my life I've never even seen
that on a ticker I've never even heard
that in the zeitgeist of what's going on
I've never even heard that uh turd in
the world and so to ever have to have
that be something that said that's
amazing I mean when I was growing up the
only black people that had money were
the Dallas Cowboys and people on that
movie coming to America those are the
only wealthy black people that you would
see and I don't mean that as a shun or
anything like that I'm talking those
that is the facts and those are the
facts from my eyes so those are just my
facts you know when I was growing up you
didn't die I didn't there wasn't a rich
black man in my town you know I remember
my mother for a while dated a man who
was black and Jewish and and he was and
I guess he one of his parents might have
been white or them yeah one of his
parents I guess was Jewish and white and
then one of his parents was black and he
was the only he was the
the closest thing I'd seen or like a
wealthy black man you know but and
here's from from New Orleans but I
didn't you know there just wasn't
something that was going on but now did
you go to Atlanta 25 years ago when you
go to Atlanta now did you go walk
through the Lenox Mall in Atlanta and
you're white you well anyway I felt like
the poorest person in town there's a lot
of black wealth you know there's a lot
of black opportunity and I'm not saying
like I've had nothing to do with this
but I'm not saying that this isn't
something that I've seen in my lifetime
and so this isn't you know it's
something that is exciting you know it's
something that is cool to see it's
something where you can see that change
can happen you know so if you if so if I
hear a stat like that or if I hear
something that's positive you know I'm
still going to be hopeful for America
whereas I feel like there's people out
there that even if say if you know the
current political regime solved all the
safely cured cancer that there's people
out there that would be like man like
like you know like they're just and at
that point it makes me wonder if I'm
thinking that way is it more about me
like what's wrong with me if I'm stuck
on that that oh it's yeah because then
it's not like it's not like I really am
interested in the world being a certain
way it's in I'm interested in the world
becoming a certain way the way that I
want it to become that way or or
something like you know what I'm saying
mm-hmm
I don't know it's just I just don't
understand you know there's so many
people that just don't even seem hopeful
you know they're like love you know love
love love love but then you know I
everything on television just so there's
just so much hate it's like how are you
gonna get to love if all you
doing is hatin all the time you know
it's the same thing that I you know that
makes you like I don't like people that
hate so much and so many you know
there's you know you see read so many
articles and so much anti USA
anti-american anti-trump sentiment and I
get it like Trump is not easily likable
at all but if you're sitting there
hating him and then they're and then
also hate and not wanting any success
for for the next few years that he's in
office or whatever then how then what
does that mean about you or what does
that mean if that's me what does that
mean about me like is it more about what
I want or is it more about what's you
know that people that things could
actually get better you know and how do
I get to and and if all I do is hate
something where's my love you know I
mean there was do growing up there was
so many like it was you know it was
tough I remember there was you know it
was tough growing up in a community
where a lot there was so much poverty in
the black community where they had just
generations of of lack of education
generations of lack of desire
generations of lack of opportunity and
then it got to the point where you know
the kids that are some of the some of
the kids that would grow up with they
just had nothing they didn't have
anything inside of them you know and I'm
not saying this to make fun of them or
to point fingers at them I'm saying this
because like there would be instances
where you know I would get jumped by
black kids or I would get you know
threatened or I had a girlfriend that
used to get you know molested if you
will by you know
tougher black guy on the school bus and
and at the time like you know I didn't
understand a lot of that stuff I didn't
understand a lot of you know where some
of these kids were in the history of
time and in their lives you know but but
ice but I would but I had to but I I
could still even though I was angry you
know over time I understood I could
understand what was going on you know I
could understand that sure even though
you know some of this behavior is out
there and some of it of course is
whoever's fault it is the actual person
doing the behavior it's their fault
there's also an element over time that
is built into their world or a lack of
elements that are built into some of
these kids lives that makes them be able
to function and be comfortable in in the
society in society and therefore you
know that's why sometimes they would act
out and behave the way they did and I
had to understand that and I would still
have to and I was still hopeful for
these kids and for these communities you
know because I even though maybe my some
of my life wasn't as bad we were still
right there you know in the same
neighborhoods and the same school bus in
the same circle and and even though I
hated I mean I hated some of their
behavior I hated being threatened and
you know I hated I hate it sometimes how
mean some of these kids were you know
and there were white kids that were -
I'm not saying that it was just one way
but but some of these kids you
there were some black kids that were so
just angry you know and so mean but I
was still hopeful even if I didn't like
them
I just ill try to be you know I think
understanding where I could and hopeful
that that things would get better and
and I'm not comparing that to what's
going on now I'm just trying to find a
correlation in my life where even if I
don't like something for me to then not
want that you know or like a person or a
group for me to not want them to succeed
just to prove my point or to prove or to
justify my angst or my anger that that
is something is wrong with me then that
that is because that's it's selfish
you know that's selfish
and it doesn't take away maybe some of
the you know that anger that I have
towards some of the kids that were you
know violent towards me when I was young
or that beat me up or that made me feel
less than or threaten me or you know did
some things that were vile that I had to
be around but it does you know but those
are instances that I would then take up
with you know with those with those I
guess with those specific people you
know but
it's I don't know man I just my brains
just getting a little bit lost but
sometimes yeah I just don't like some of
the energy that's out there where it's
not about getting better as a group and
there's not even a look towards that
horizon there's just a I want to see
some failure so that I can be right
because we just it's not it's not for
the betterment of everyone then we're
not going to you can't we can't get
better like that as a group I don't
think you know and I could be wrong and
I'm not I'm not trying to offend anybody
I'm just trying to think and be alive at
the same time and trying to feel and
talk at the same time which most of my
life has been really tough for me to do
[Music]
just because sometimes I over the years
I don't even know how I was feeling you
know and I think I was also just been
afraid sometimes to to talk you know
always did humor or told jokes and stuff
like that and that sort of behavior
because it was the only language that I
really I don't know it's the only
language really that I knew you know and
sometimes I get scared I think and
that's where I think a lot of my fear
came in on the last episode and it
probably will again where I just get
scared I just get scared you know being
brave enough to say what is okay for me
and what my life is and what's going on
with me and being brave enough to tell
my story you know and nothing honestly
dude nothing has made me feel like I
moved out here to Los Angeles to be more
free you know I mean I love Louisiana I
love my home state I love I love you
know that small-town vibe I love a sense
of community that the that a sense of
community saved me from
from who knows what save me from a lot
of stuff there's a lot of people that
lended their heart and their you know
their concern and their home even to
make me feel okay but I get out here in
Los Angeles and I sometimes I can't even
tell I feel like my story doesn't even
exist
you know because suddenly there's this
there's just this you know ghost in the
air this there's this mmm does this
thing where people want to they don't
want to look at the big picture they
want to be right and some guy out here
who you know who you know of some you
know white kid who is you know is trying
not to be racist and trying not to be a
[ __ ] you know you know try not to be
a pervert for sure I'm always trying
that I mean everybody knows I'm trying
not to jerk off locally or even when I'm
out of town but you know it's like just
because I don't sound and look just like
everybody who's just on this you know
this cookie cutter plate that I'm not
accepted you know with that um you know
immediately people just look and judge
even though Hollywood's always about
like oh oh love love you know love
acceptance yeah we'll try walking into a
try walking into a conversation out here
with a with a gender-neutral haircut and
in a southern accent and see how much
people are just like Oh immediately
don't say this guy's this way or this
guy's that way you know I've never felt
I've never honestly felt more oppressed
in my life and I grew up in apparently
one of the most you know racist
environments of the world you know but
uh the oppression I felt heaviest in my
life here in Los Angeles you know they
just try to beat a you know you just
just frustrating anyway I don't want to
take us down that path man this isn't
about me but I appreciate you guys being
here with me there's been a lot of talk
recently uh you know a lot of people
asking me on
social media about Tom Segura and he is
a fellow comedian and he's a very unique
man and and he has a great podcast
called your mom's house and he and he
made fun of Louisiana he was making fun
of Louisiana in one of his comedic sets
and he was talking about Louisiana and
build a wall around it and and he talked
about he's the word [ __ ] and this
has just been an uproar about it and a
lot of people asking me how I feel and
you know what's funny is before I even
knew that this was on on television when
people could watch it or on netflix
where people could watch it I had I
heard Tom do the do that bit I heard Tom
do that set in at the Comedy Store a
couple of months ago and I'm sitting in
the back and new my first my first
feeling was that I was offended I'm like
man what the [ __ ] dude you're gonna make
fun of Louisiana you know why don't you
make fun of one of these you know one of
these show-offs and one of these
know-it-all places you know once you
make fun of a Los Angeles or uh or in
New York you know or a California or New
York make fun of a know-it-all kind of
place I'm like you're picking the lowest
hanging fruit there Tom Tomcat and then
I'm watching I'm like you know and then
I realized I have a part in my Netflix
special there's a bit where I make fun
of Mississippi which is an even easier
place to make fun of so that's when I
realized you know what like this is just
jokes even though it might first hit me
a little bit uncomfortable because
that's my home state you know that these
are just jokes I mean I could go you
know I could raise rebuttal up forever
Louisiana Purchase well one of the
greatest deals ever in the universe we
did that you're welcome
okay bought most of America for ten
cents an acre
boomtown you know I could say that you
know I could say that you know one of
the psuedo birthplaces of jazz
you know I could say that we've had you
know a lot of amazing people come out of
Louisiana you know I could say you know
of some of the greatest recipes you do
come on they got some trout they have
some trout down there that if you eat it
that you're one of your deceased
grandparents could probably get that
taste in their mouth even in their
skeleton wherever they're laying they
could get that taste in their mouth and
so that's when I realized you know what
I sure I could rebuttal but the thing is
is that it's jokes and that's Tom's take
on it and he said build a wall around
Louisiana and so that's his tape and
that's it you know I just have to you
know I got to realize some things are
just jokes especially because if I start
to question you know what you know I can
say if it's if I think it's funny or not
but if I start to question what he
should be able to joke about it's like
come on and especially in the south we
should be able to take a joke and
there's a lot of places that cannot take
jokes but I don't think that other South
is one of them and and you know in
Thomas to go down there and perform and
I'm not gonna people are asking if I'm
gonna be a security guard down there if
I'm gonna be down there opening up not
that I know of
you know but good and I wish Tom the
best down there I wish him the best you
know a lot of famous people have been
killed and even if you know if somebody
shoots him up a lot of famous people
have been killed in Louisiana a lot man
Huey P long Pistol Pete Maravich Steven
Segal Jim Croce or crotchy Larry Sweeney
there you go so you know it's anybody's
ballgame down there Tomcat good luck you
know good luck and but I'm not a Fant be
offended so after what I've done I have
to I think we're almost getting you in
and living out in Los Angeles and even
just being in this world today it's that
offensive that it's becoming that
culture it even if infects me because I
wouldn't usually get offended but my
first thought was to be offended and I
think my reasoning was I just feel like
that that the south and that the Midwest
these places have been picked on enough
you know but then when I look at my own
work even though I'm from one of these
places Here I am picking on it so it
just uh you know at that point I just
kind of realized that Tom's just telling
jokes and then it made me think well
maybe I should find out you know a
braver place to make fun of I mean at
least you picked Louisiana I picked
Mississippi which is even you know which
is a which you know usually it's like
you go down like every state makes fun
of another state like oh yeah well you
know North Carolina is like oh well you
think we're shady what about South
Carolina and South Carolina is like oh
well you think we're shady what about
Kentucky and Kentucky is like Oh were
you think we're shitty what about
Alabama and it keeps going but then you
get to mrs. hippy and Mississippi's like
oh you think we're shitty well and they
don't know because there's no other
states left but then also you go to
Mississippi man and you find some people
that are you got a lot more weight you
go to some of these these you know um
you go to some of these Southern and
Midwestern states many have so much more
good-heartedness
he has so much more people actually
living their lives and getting to know
each other you know I mean Los Angeles
we sit in traffic everybody acts like
it's so diverse out here like yeah
there's a lot of different types of
people but it's not like they interact
all the time
everybody's for the most part seems to
be in traffic driving to their own
little insular universe like there's a
lot of in Psych
you know there's little neighborhoods
where everybody's kind of very similar
you know it's just like then we go into
our homes and talk about how and people
talk about how now diverse and how
loving they are but I've I've known my
neighbors way less when I've lived in
Los Angeles then I have any other place
that I've lived in America and that's
true I've known I've known my neighbors
more in other places including New York
City South Carolina New Orleans Arizona
I knew my neighbors more in those places
than I have living here the entire and
I've been here for probably about 13 or
14 years now I'm not saying that's not
great great things about California you
know I'm not saying they're not great
things about Los Angeles but as a place
where there's a strong sense of
community anybody who tells you that
there is I think is not realistic I
think that that's there's very there's
not it's very me
everything is very me out here and I
don't even know why sometimes I don't
know why I feel that way or why it is
that way you know I'm actually met a man
on the street earlier and this was like
the first time I said I said yeah hey
man I you know I live right down the
street it at this address and if you
ever need anything you know you if you
and your wife need ever need anything or
whatever you know I'm down the street I
just realized this was just tonight when
I want to let's run I was like man I've
never even said that [ __ ] to anybody
before so I don't know I mean the only
time I knew I had a neighbor at one of
my old places and he and he didn't he he
uh had husbands or men he you know
preferred the pleasure of men and they
used to get up there and sometimes dude
I'd be laying in bed at night listening
to these men make love kind of in the
distance and and damn sometimes it was
you know it didn't make me erect or
anything like that but it was it was
probably the most I've ever even knew my
neighbors really in a weird way
you know is probably the closest that I
got to know in any of my neighbors was
sometimes listening to this man who used
to make soap he also made so he was soap
soap ceman her suds man I don't even
know I could look it up on my Internet's
having trouble I would let you know and
I would listen to him and and he had a
couple of different partners I think but
that's his [ __ ] that's his life you know
and it was but that's weird that that
was kind of the closest thing I felt to
neighbourly association was listening a
couple fellas moving furniture if you
will you know a couple of a couple of
lunch hunters you know people hunting
just getting into the dark arts out
there all right let's get into a little
more stuff here let's get into a follow
up from some of the stuff that happened
last week you guys hit some calls and I
really appreciate it
I'm not gonna let you know a bunch of
dates but I will let you know if you
look on YouTube a I'll ask you to
subscribe please and be I'll let you
know I got this onward t-shirt and they
got these onward shirts now at theof on
comm slash store sto re where you can
support the podcast and that is what is
going on I'll let you know when I'll be
in Portland next weekend at Harveys and
we're gonna go meet up with the hamster
rancher so they had a man that called in
a while back and he ranch his hands and
this gentleman we had a conversation
with me other night on the phone on the
telephone and he's still out there
working with him and he was feeding a
couple of them you know in a bottle not
breasts and that's you know and that's
the way to do it I guess if you're
feeding a big group and especially if
you're not related to him if you're a
man but he was doing that and he was
being out there and being regular with
these animals and and so we're gonna go
meet up with him and get out in and see
a lot of these beautiful hamsters and so
I'm very excited about that so I'm
looking forward to that next week but we
had some calls that came in from you
guys and these are gonna be brought to
you by grey block pizza and gray block
pizza that's over there 18:11 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles and I'm going
to read you one of the different type of
pizza they have right
and this Pizza called the navei Bianco
the Nephi Bianco in this red onion fresh
sliced tomato Mazzarella ricotta ricotta
cheese with garlic basil on a garlic
pesto sauce and that's that never Vianca
18:11 Pico Boulevard Los Angeles go to
great block get that and we're so
grateful to them and happy to uh just
the support that they've given also
grateful to you guys over the patreon
and links to great block great block and
patreon are going to be in the in the
comments you can grab those and check
them out and see what they're doing
we had a guy call in last week and his
wife had been drinking and she'd been
getting that liquor you know and when a
woman gets a liquor in her and look I'm
a FEMINIST as they come you know you
want to see a lady out there doing
something wild let's see it you want to
see a lady I mean look I think ladies
we're doing just fine
they got the Statue of Liberty what else
did they got uh okay so maybe we do need
a little bit more you know we might need
you know if you want to put a couple
days in the NFL than do it but I don't
see that as their quality I just see
that as forcing women into the NFL you
know but um but they had to you know a
lady that caught a man called in and
said his wife was out there drinking
doing liquor and having liquor inside of
her she just started drinking and that
she had recently hooked up with his
brother's wife it was this gentleman
that called my wife recently started
drinking like a couple weeks ago her
first real night was getting hammered
drunk she wasn't with me she's with her
cousin and she ended up texting the boy
that she hooked up with yeah and that's
the caller and then he goes on to say
that the that his wife hooked up with
his sister-in-law and look I mean I've
seen some things on the internet you
know and I've been out there on some of
them you know crazy websites where you
hear them blow jobs going on and and
some of them site
have good [ __ ] on me you know
something somebody's washing a car you
know we're putting a sponge in a bucket
one of them real hearty [ __ ] you
know seemed like somebody been you know
working their neck out before they even
show up to to you know do some work on
that car but this but this guy have
family this family getting involved now
and he said that that was going on his
wife out there you know being wild and
being sentimental and they'd been at his
brother's house and the wife had snuck
out and made made you know woman love
which I still don't know how they do it
really because I've even drawn some
pictures and it doesn't you know some
parts of it don't add up and I made some
beautiful woman love though but I do
enjoy watching it but I'm trying not to
right now but had made some woman love
and so here's some of you guys as
responses let's get into it
hey PA I'm just calling in response to
the guy who his his wife was doing some
fine angling with his sister-in-law and
I have a similar experience my ex she
hooked up with a local resident horn on
my back quite frankly that enraged me
because not only it just seems like a
breach of trust and I'm not really into
two lesbians and stuff like that so it
didn't really excite me so I think it's
normal to be you know upset by that but
basically you should just ask her if
it's yep there you did something with
someone else even another guy if that be
all right with her and if it's not then
obviously the scales are a little off
and that's probably unhealthy for your
relationship Wow okay and I appreciate
that call Ryan thank you for calling in
yeah there's a lot there was a lot right
there in in Ryan's call because he's
saying that this happened to him and you
could tell a little bit in his voice
that there was still a little you know
probably still a little bit of
resentment there towards his wife and
I'm guesstimating Ryan I could be wrong
and I'm sorry if I'm not trying to judge
you
I appreciate your call man it's you know
you know you put you're trying to help
out this other gentleman you know and
that's you know we're grateful for that
but you know yeah your wife hooked up
with a local lesbian now that's the
thing now sometimes a lot of like some
lesbian women will even seek out a small
community where there are not a lot of
lesbian women you know because then they
become that maverick you know they
become this they become that other sweet
treat in the distance because they have
you know they probably have a you know a
lot of lesbians there they have a lot
they got that you know they have my you
know nice etiquette nice things going on
they got you know they're they're active
in this in the community you know and so
then they're meeting women and then if a
woman has trouble with her man next
thing you know who can she go talk to is
always available that lesbian that local
lesbian and so next thing you know you
over by that local lesbian tell us and
that's a beautiful little trap they got
going on now a man as a man I'm envious
of lesbians you know because they get
they are they can they can set up the
same old little trap to meet ladies that
we used to set up but our traps been
figured out you know I can't just talk
to a guy's wife and have it seem like
I'm not up to no good
or a man can't do that but a local
lesbian can do that you know they can be
like oh come over you know let's do some
you know you know I got this new
full-body crossword or you know where I
got um you know I got a you know I got
this you know new juggling kit let's
learn how to juggle or let's do
something let's bake you know let's bake
these are you know I'm with her cookies
and next thing you know they're falling
in love these two women and so obviously
you know Ryan said that his wife you
know had made out with a local lesbian
and that that even though it was a woman
that that challenged his comfort and he
think this that that compromised his his
confidence in the relationship in his
relationship and so he is
recommended to you that you asked her if
you can do the same thing but now here's
the problem if a man goes and does the
same thing then the man is out there and
he's involved with other men and that's
fine but it's for some reason there's
still this this thing where it's not as
what is that excuse me what is that
thing
because yeah if a woman goes out and
about and there's a you know a lick I
don't know if they call that lipstick
lesbian but if a woman if your wife goes
out and about it makes out with another
woman it doesn't seem as taboo as if
your husband goes out and makes out with
another man you know is it because that
you know that trying or a woman being a
lesbian is more it's just it's II it's
is it because is it looked at easier is
it just different is it because the
sexual act if a man goes out with a if
your husband if a woman's husband were
to go out and be with another man that
that sexual act is more it's more
aggressive is that what makes it seem
more taboo because Ryan here is telling
is telling this man we'll ask ask your
wife if you can go be with another man
if you can go do the same thing and if
she says no then then hold her
accountable because what she's doing
isn't fair but I'm gonna say you know
Ryan I think it's you know that's good
advice but then if he goes out and does
that he you know he has to go what if
she says yes now he has to go be with
another man just to get even with his
wife so now he's out there blowing dudes
you know and just frisking out and some
dudes you know and you know in in some
fellas kitchen or whatever or by
candlelight you know watching old
episodes of magnum p.i or you know who
knows you know and he doesn't even want
to be he's just trying to get even with
his wife that can be a little bit scary
I can be a little bit scary dude
so that's another option you can get out
there in full and
with other men locally in order to make
things even with your wife see how she
feels and maybe that's not a bad idea
you know bring home a beautiful little
you know a beautiful little Fauntleroy a
gentleman you know next time you and
your wife are you about to sit down to
dinner there's a little at the door and
who's that oh that's just my buddy
Randall spelled are a ND l e and next
thing you know Randall comes in you know
and he's being wild and he's got a new
necklace or something the next thing you
know all of you guys are you know it's
Taco Tuesday
but Randall's over there snacking on
some taquitos and trying to send your
wife a message snacking on some thick
taquitos and trying to send your wife a
message maybe that's how you do it maybe
that's how you show her you know how it
would feel if the if the pages were
turned let's take another call here here
we go oh this trip you got me oh whoa
what's up brother my name is Joe I got
us some advice for this fella that his
wife is getting into the dark arts via
the way of the alcohol I guess this is
the first time she started drinking some
straitlaced before this happened and
then just took if we drink the alcohol
now this behavior has come about I would
suggest that she probably stopped man
because that's a slippery slope man I
can see her in six months down to
Tijuana getting a double dick by two
dudes while snorting coke out of a
hookers ass or something you know what I
mean whoo and that's singing Joe right
there and singing Joe that's a deep I
mean that's a long so you're saying if
she has a little bit of liquor and next
thing you know she's texting
ex-boyfriends that's the part that gets
me even more is that she's texting a
high school boyfriend you know you guys
are married she's texting a high school
boyfriend
dude I would get I did a comedy show one
night and a gal that I dated in high
school came and she was with her husband
and she got drunk and when she was
leaving when they were leaving she was
like reaching for me and I'm no catch
first of all that was my first thought
but my second thought was
this is awkward because I felt awkward
for the guy it was only because of the
alcohol so yeah alcohol can have a wild
effect it can be a slippery slope yeah
it's like where does this end if first
he's texting other her exes and then
next thing you know she's you know
gallivanting with local Manolo caillois
lesbians then what what's the next level
you know she's out there she's you know
doing buying kilos or she's drugged
mewling for you know hardcore lesbians
you know she's doing skate skateboarding
I don't know who knows man a lot of
possibilities but but yeah I don't know
if she could go that far wording up is
down in Tijuana that seems a bit much Jo
so I'm no cartographer but uh I think
that that you know there's other more
local things could occur before she ends
up down there caught up like that you
know you made it sound like she's really
really caught up and I must play one
more time what you said her slope man I
can see her in six months down to
Tijuana getting a double dick by two
dudes well Norton coked out of a hookers
ass or something yeah Jo and that is
really I don't think that that's that's
not what I see and I'm no crystal ball
or but that's not what I see let's get
another call here we go hey this is
Nathan and Anchorage Alaska today I'm
calling about the gentleman whose wife
has just started drinking said he was
confused that he's supposed to like you
know girl-on-girl action most guys do
well first off guys like girl-on-girl
action when they are involved that's
true because then all you're thinking
about is being left out it's like
looking at pictures of your friends at
the beach you know being at the beach is
cool looking at pictures of your friends
at the beach not as cool but thanks for
calling from Alaska man I like Alaska
and I like I like callers from Alaska
because Alaskans have time to think you
know and Nathan from Alaska he probably
he pot I mean who could hear you know it
sometimes just nighttime up there it's
nighttime up there for like four months
that's crazy if you don't think you have
a boogie man on your bed
your debt you have to four months
there's no way that the dark arts don't
really creep in creep up over the
horizon nighttime for months that's got
the devil signature all over the bottom
of it let's hear more Nathan she's
sitting on the sidelines watching his
wife hook up with other chicks maybe
it's not quite as fun sounds like her
drinking has really escalated she just
started drinking maybe you sure the
ropes a little bit
you know you don't want to do 15 Jager
bombs in 15 minutes yeah that could be
it you know that's a way to do it is to
try drinking together
I am concerned with why she just started
drinking you know maybe she's just
getting a little bit of her over college
out you know over of her you know she's
maybe did she miss that experience and
that's what she's getting into
um and there's also there's like some
adult fun camp so you guys could go to I
know it's like a crazy idea maybe but
there's like these summer camps you can
find online for adults it's like three
or four days you fly in and it's like a
big party where everybody gets to have
fun there might be some swinging you
know swingers going on I'm not sure but
I've seen some photos and some of the
people on there look a little bit like
they'd be in the swinging but that could
be it you know that's an option you know
she's she's getting involved in you know
if already she's reaching out you know
like I'm dating your brother's wife
that's just it's that what's next you
know you know she's snuggling it you
know she's sneaking to your
grandmother's bed like what is next man
you know she's doing nah you know
hospice care for your grandmother but
taking things to another level like
what's next so that's you might want to
look into that you might want to look
into that but yeah I'd stay out stay
cognizant know what's going on you know
cuz that's pretty that's a lot you got a
lot going on right there you know but I
would communicate with her how you feel
so that if she you know if certain
behaviors occur or continue to occur and
she
and she knows how you feel then at least
you're gonna have in in the in the court
of emotion when you guys discuss stuff
you're gonna you're gonna your case is
going to have your a lot of your case
will already have been presented along
the way you know so trying to
communicate all I think could be helpful
there but I don't know yeah but she
started you know she uh you know found
that local lesbian as a man I remember
they had a couple ladies in our town
furniture movers and these was some
early lesbians back in the day a lot of
lesbians were in the furniture moving
business
and antiques antiquing and and they
moved it I remember ordering a loveseat
off the internet and they brought it and
they are not the internet off the phone
that's when you called a number on the
television and they brought it over and
they ended up moving in our neighborhood
they brought some they bought some drugs
and moved into our neighborhood and they
they made love to a couple people's
mothers over about the next decade
probably six to eight people's Mother's
all right
but that's all the responses to the
calls from last week if you have if you
have a question a concern something
that's going on in your life you can hit
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three we're going to get
into just a couple more calls that came
in that were not related to that to that
to that to that wife Fiasco that's going
on up there let's get into one of those
right now here we go
Theo von is Kenneth from Las Vegas
Nevada what's up Kenneth calling in from
Las Vegas that's a Sin City and now you
sound young and who knows how old you
how old you'll actually be able to get
growing up there in sin let's go more
under the United States Air Force I
thank you for your service I just wanted
to know your thoughts on gambling I'm
down a couple hundred want to know
should I keep doing it is it something's
bad that I'm in but man let me tell you
I think I should I want to hit the big
money I want to hit it not just for me
but for everybody one of your opinion on
it
our guards of gamblin well first of all
Kenneth thanks
second of all you you said should I
you're down a couple hundred should I
and then I love the fact that you
immediately think you should that's
obvious you're obviously at the casino
right now and have ducked off to the
side to to make the call
and look man gambling's fun dude
gambling is fun I remember I was at the
casino playing craps one time in New
Orleans and I won I think probably $1100
and I bought bathing suits for everybody
at the craps table everybody got afraid
everybody got a bathing suit you know
and a buddy of mine another time bought
an iron bought a clothing iron for
everybody everybody at the table got an
iron so there's a lot of good
opportunities in casinos but you said
this is my favorite part of your call
right here let's hear it something's bad
I'm in but man let me tell you I think I
should I want to hit the big money I
want to hit it not just for me but for
everybody yeah that's a cool excuse I
want to hit the big money not just for
me but for everybody for who for America
for who who are we talking about
everybody most people are probably
asleep it sounds like this is at the
middle of the night you know Gamlen look
if you can have fun with it that's fun
if you wake up tomorrow morning and you
have to go gamble again there might be
an issue you know I think you just have
to look at your own track record only
you know if you got a problem but
gambling gambling can be risky man I'll
tell you this I'll tell you this
gambling story I saw a dude one time at
a party right and uh and he bet he bet
this hot girl this hot chick he bet her
he said if I let your friend the hot
chicks friend was a man and he was a gay
male
he said if I let your friend give me a
[ __ ] will you have sex with me and
the girl said yes if you let my friend
give you a [ __ ] I'll have sex with
you so then the dude let's the gay guy
give them a [ __ ]
then the girl bails out of the [ __ ]
deal
so I mean that's what you get for
gambling you know what are you gonna do
you know you place your bet and I'm not
gonna say you lost I mean you got a
[ __ ] out of it that's what the guy
got but not from you not from who he
wanted so it's just risky gambling's
rescue man so if you want to gamble you
go on but you be careful that's all I'm
saying
we've got another call that came in here
and this is from Ben he wants to know
it's about a stalker let's hear it
yo what's up man my name is Ben and I
got a little bit of a situation here
this girl I've been seeing her for a
while now and she's calling out this
thing going on where we're doing our
thing it's not like exclusive or nothing
but we know we get down and all that
okay gang gang man you got that let's
hear more it's been going on for
probably eight months now something like
that that's pretty crispy dude eight
months bro you know I'm saying that's
real stuff some dude in some places up
to marriage if you guys die in a month
that's you know that's what I'm really
pertain to it but still eight months is
a long time let's hear more and she
recently told me that she's got a little
bit of a stalking situation and not
exactly a little bit because of the dude
is literally like outside her door every
day she wakes up and he is just there
hmm he wakes she wakes up and he's just
there he's not a roommate huh let's hear
more it's kind of awkward because we all
kind of go to the same school and he's
in one of her classes and it's been
going apparently this is no one on for
like nine months or so mm-hmm and she
said she tried to like switch up her
roots last year and all that and he
still somehow found a way to find her
just first time I'm hearing about it
hey stalkers gonna start you know I mean
if he's obviously good at what he does
you have to respect that a little bit
you don't want one of these weak-ass
stalkers that's kind of you know
well maybe do one a week a stalker let's
hear more about it and I guess he
thought she could handle it on her own
and she finally came to
you know chef [ __ ] this dude up er yeah
I don't really want to start a fight
because I don't want to get in shoulders
right you only get in self with the
school and I'm just I'm cutting that
call there but look you got a stalker a
couple things couple ways to go about it
you know if you fight a stalker I mean
it's just gonna you know he's obviously
a sick guy there's something wrong there
so maybe even having a conversation with
him
you know maybe saying look guy what's
going on you know like I'm not angry at
you I don't think you're a bad person
but this is what's going on it makes me
admit this is this is how it's placed to
us and it makes us feel uncomfortable
you know like you know I'm trying to
have a relationship with this girl and
you're trying to [ __ ] you know hang
out in the garden and looking through
the windows and it's not we're not
working conducive ly together so maybe
just being real with him about it you
know talking about it like that now if
he continues to escalate now you said
your girl might want to fight him that's
probably a better way to go then my you
slipping and in fighting them so at
least that way you know it's her because
these days if you know a woman can beat
up a stalker and that's nothing I mean
that's like nothing's gonna happen to
anybody you know not to her you know I
mean it's carte blanche on stalkers
right now every stalker is getting their
ass whipped by you know a lot of women
or kickbox and everything just a beat up
stalker so if you even used to stalk and
don't anymore and have moved on from it
and even started your own family women
are gonna track you down probably beat
your ass now because they can it's that
time times up for stalkers so I would
you know I would talk to the guy and
then if it still escalates I would have
your chick fight him that's what I would
do push each colon though let's uh let's
hit this call right here here we go
hey yo Co man this is Nikki calling from
Seattle so here's my situation though
I'm 30 years old thanks for calling in
Mickey from Seattle and I will actually
be up in in Seattle or Tacoma Knicks in
a couple of weeks next month I think
and I'm currently at the end stage of a
lung disease now my current lungs don't
have very long left by about two and a
half years hopefully we can stretch them
out but the silver lining is that I'm
gonna be soon on the lung transplant
list I'm hoping I'm gonna get wicked
Wow man congratulations on that so you
got two and a half you got two and a
half you got two and a half years ya
left on these ballast tanks you got in
you now and then you got you're gonna
get on the transplant list that's
beautiful when I was young my sister was
born with like a rare disease called
biliary atresia and she got a liver
transplant when I was 14 but I remember
being young and we uh we spent a lot of
time filling out these envelopes and
mailing them off to strangers to get
them to donate money to get that liver
you know cuz you got to get that liver
and I remember getting pissed even
because I'll you know there'll be [ __ ] I
didn't get [ __ ] for Christmas or
whatever and I'd be pissed and my sister
was gonna get a liver and I wasn't
getting you know some [ __ ] new BK
nights or some you know some type of
[ __ ] or some socks or whatever
onward which will give me a few more
years to figure this whole thing out and
it's been a really difficult time and
I've been single through it my question
to you man is during this difficult time
that's really ruins my confidence I
wanted to ask you and the viewers what
they think what are some good steps that
I can take to start boosting my
confidence and my self-worth to be able
to start getting back out there and
started talking to girls again damn boy
freaking no long Mickey out there in the
universe you know we got that laughs he
got a you know a couple years left on
him lungs and he trying to inhale a
little bit of love into his life that
sounds like man that's brave you know
that's ballsy you know cuz a lot of
people they got a couple years left they
could and it's obviously it sounds to me
it's obvious you're looking for a little
bit of love a little bit of that a or to
pump you know you're trying to get that
hitter up in your sister land diastole
because if he's looking for sex you can
get sex go to backpage.com go to eros
net you got a free salmon net and get
sex if you want it but obviously looking
for love so that's it you know what
maybe we leave look guys if you have
advice for Tom this dude's got two and a
half years left on his lungs and I'm
guessing if you don't get new lungs you
know it's a breathers ballgame out here
in the universe and I'm not trying to be
cold to you but you probably know it
better than anybody Tomcat or Mickey
sorry I don't know why I called you
Tomcat because I wasn't paying attention
to my own thoughts but Mickey it's it
you know it's a breathers game out here
if you ain't breathing you out and I
hope that doesn't happen for you man but
and what I would like to do is yeah I'd
like to ask our Coulter's if you have
advice Mickey's got a couple years left
you know he's got them terminal lungs
dude's got you know he got them luck
he's coming in light in the lungs and
what would he suggest for him you know
how do you meet a lady some girls might
think it's cool you don't even be around
for a long time you know like I'm in
that damn that's dark I'm sorry I guess
I'm feeling kind of maybe a little bit
dark but that might be a good pick-up
strategy you know hey guess what you
know will you only got to take me for a
couple year you know like maybe lay down
some money on your life insurance and
you know hit a lady up that way it's a
dark take but I think these days if a
woman has a sense of humor she's gonna
like that you know cuz women want that
rescue and you got that rescue right now
you have that rescue that's all over you
you know women want that you know that
uh they want that man on that transplant
list they want that man who's you know
long you know maybe he's you know on a
kit you know having a kidney issue or
something you know has been in a you
know a fire or something
the women are intrigued by that they
want that rescue it's in their blood to
want to help so I think you're gonna
have that going for you but how do you
boost that confidence yeah that's wild
you know that's really really wild but I
think
probably comes back to how do we all
boost our confidence and part of it is
just you know I don't know if maybe some
women have let you down or made you feel
bad because of this issue but if they
have me you got to get back on there and
just keep trying you know it's just like
last week when I didn't even know if I
wanted a you know I couldn't do it but I
just you know came back this week you
know I had a freaking strap my lungs
back in and get back into the studio but
I can say this man I'm gonna be up in
Seattle up in your area in Tacoma let me
look and see what I am maybe we can find
you a date what about that that's a good
idea I'll be up there in March 15th and
16th I'll be in Tacoma at the comedy
club so ladies if there's anybody that
lives in Seattle or if you're a man and
you have a friend that live out there
that might be interested in meeting a
guy like Tom you know that ticking time
bomb because that dude only got so much
time oh it's not even Tom it seems
[ __ ] Mickey damn [ __ ] dude sorry bro
well look bruh who cares what your name
is dude you know what I'm saying it's
not about your name it's about you know
that you have bad lungs and that this is
you know that what are you gonna do and
I'm gonna try to boost your confidence a
little bit by saying let's catch up when
I'm out there in Tacoma and let's get
you a date that's [ __ ] Trickey Mickey
dude you know he's got them tricky air
bags inside of him you know he's got two
and a half years left on his lungs he
got them least he's got them least lungs
you know and I had a bad lease on a car
a couple years back and it's not the
same thing but you know you only get so
I only got so many miles I can only
drive I got 4,000 miles a year on a
lease and Jesus it it was miserable I
remember pushing that something I would
have to push my car to get to where I
was going to not have it or Domino rack
up and because it's expensive but yeah
let's see if we if you have any ideas
for Tom for boosting
confidence when he's under the under the
gun of physical impairments I know we
got a boy down there in Alabama who
doesn't have a leg and he stays
confident and I'd look to see maybe what
his thoughts are if he doesn't mind
hitting the hotline again if you have an
impairment and you and you and you you
deal with the confidence but you you got
some ideas for my boy once you hit us up
and let us know and we'll see if we
can't help him out that's exactly what
I'm thinking right there let's take this
one last call right here and this is
from Tom here we go Atos boys - rural
North Carolina I've been kind of
dabbling in the dark arts recently in
this dark artist Tom from rural North
Carolina and I do remember you Tom early
caller from the beginning of the show
thank you been talking to this chick
online super cool but she's got a
boyfriend and I'm a single guy so
there's nothing wrong with me but the
amount of time she spends texting me and
talking to me and snap chatting me and
there's nothing like it's a little
flirty but it's nothing like sexual it's
nothing super mistress I think of her
boyfriends all the stuff all the he'd be
thrilled I don't know what I'm doing is
right like I really like the girl I
think she really likes me a lot a little
bit more than just casual friends she's
not happy with her current boyfriend but
she's not necessarily looking to leave
and am i doing the right thing with
doing this and if she's doing it to this
guy you know will she turn around threw
it to me later or I kind of feel she
doing this dude okay so you texting the
guy's girlfriend you know I'm gonna tell
you here's all I'll say if you get
murdered by this guy a lot of people
aren't going to feel that sorry for you
you know it's risky you know you're
fulfilling a need but you're not you
know you're not standing up for yourself
if it's just it's just risky man you
don't know that dude
you don't know what he's into you don't
know how much he you know he might have
anger towards his he might have anger
towards hurry I'll take that on you if
he finds out you know it's risky it's
risky dude
so I don't know what to tell you but I
think you probably know what to tell
yourself you know if you textin some
man's girlfriend just even saying that
sound it out I'm texting some man's
girlfriend if that dude shows up and
wants to bake me a brisket made out of
my own ass I can't be surprised dude
when that dude warms my ass up with his
fist when that dude beats my ass so be
safe out there time it's all I can tell
you bro is this dangerous this ain't no
game that's like little Kenneth out
there gambling out there down 201/2 win
money for America
you know when people's out here having
an doing you know getting [ __ ] from
you know people of the same sex and they
don't that's not what they planned on
the dark arts abound Tom and if you
don't believe that then I don't know
what to tell you but if you guys got
some advice from Mickey then hit us up
on that and uh oh how ironic that I kept
messing up the name Tom and then a Tom
actually was our last caller today but
thank you guys for supporting the
podcast you can find all the dates at
theof on calm slash tour you can find
links below and and we'll be back on
Monday with a little bit of the state of
the podcast address and and that's it
man I want to thank Stevie starlight for
hitting us up with that hitter out the
gate today let's take it away again
we're back
look if last week didn't go great for
you come back make that bounce back know
what I'm saying
homework we back
[Applause]
[Music]
this for all the dudes out there
accidentally blow getting [ __ ] from
other dudes just to try to meet a woman
[Music]
for all the gents out there who don't
even have any lungs and they just trying
to meet a woman just trying to get one
more hit of love you want that love you
just got to open your window sometimes
maybe you just gotta you gotta say never
too late
[Applause]
some way
but that love in a universe baby
[Music]
cigar
it's never too late to let love come out
to let forgiveness come over
[Music]
it's never too late
to turn your anger into hope it's on us
ma'am all right man you guys be good to
yourselves I'll see you on Mondays
episode thank you guys for all the nice
support this past week man I needed it
and I'm back